dramamine area will tell us how to
control probabilistic systems and then
party a reservation okay thanks so first
of all I'd like to thank the organizers
of this workshop for giving me the
opportunity to give this talk and also
the more broadly the organizers of the
program for inviting me so I'll be
staying here a month so all of October
so this is in this talk I'd like to
introduce one of my research topic and
yeah if you see connections to your work
or if you're interested in some problems
i'll mention then i'll be happy to
discuss them further during the month of
october or later okay so in this talk
i'll try to give some techniques or at
least some rather well-known results
about controlling probabilistic systems
when you only partially observe them and
for this given my background I'd taken
automated or verification approach so it
might be different to some what some of
you would do in their domain so the talk
will mainly survey some existing results
but also give a few open questions and
and discuss some research direction I'd
like to investigate so first of all why
am i interested in in that problem so
why probabilities so maybe this is a
slide that you will hold agree with I
hope so web probabilities well
probabilities are very convenient if you
want to model randomized algorithms
example and we know that randomized
algorithm are needed to solve some
problem that data basic algorithm cannot
solve everything they can be used also
to model some unpredictable behaviors
it's quite convenient when you don't
know exactly what will happen to pontiff
I over the possibilities using
probabilities
and it's very similarly you can also be
seen as an abstraction of
non-determinism okay now why partial
observation so in my opinion at least
that there could be two different
motivations for that so the first one is
that if you have a huge system then it's
very likely that you can describe it
with I precision and you might want to
in order to describe it you might want
to forget about some details and if you
forget about some details it basically
so maybe you forget about some values
the values of some variables or stuff
like that and this pretty much amounts
to a I think only partial observation of
the state of the system so this first
reason is yeah maybe the system is just
too large you can describe it very
precisely very accurately the second
reason can be something that you wish
unlike the the first the first
motivation and namely for security
concerns it might be good but that the
user doesn't know everything from the
system is they are using so if the user
is an attacker then you like to prevent
the attacker to know everything that's
going on in the system okay so in this
talk i will consider models that combine
probabilities and partial observation
and these models are some extensions or
some variants of automata so AI depicted
two examples of such models maybe let's
start with the one on the right hand
side so maybe colors are not very
visible that with this cloud what i want
to represent is that an attacker how our
user cannot distinguish to the three
states one two and three okay so this is
not the
user will not be able to distinguish in
which state the system is whether it's
one two or three but it will be able to
know whether the city is wo RL and the
left hand side is another example of
partial observation in which what I mean
that I this is that the user will not
distinguish will not see all events all
actions that happen and some of them are
won't be visible so these two actions
will not be visible to an external user
okay so we will have such models like
automata and with partial observation I
cannot see the precise state of the
system or I cannot see all the actions
that happened in the system and for all
this talk we still the attacker or the
user will know the model so it will know
that the system is executing that
particular model okay so on such models
we can ask several questions so first of
all we can start with language tility
questions so poetic automata an example
of I will develop that that prosecutor
metal an example of model combining
probabilities and partial observation
and you can be interested in defining
languages that are recognizable by pro
se corta matter another kind of problem
is is monitoring so if you assume that
you passively observe the behavior of
the system what can you deduce from your
observations so maybe you would like to
be able to diagnose that fault occurred
in the system or maybe you want just to
supervise its behavior in order to know
what what what has been going on modern
early okay and the last possibility
which we will be focusing on in this
talk is the class of control problems so
I assume that the user of the attacker
is active and can interact with the
system and more specifically the
objective of the user we
be to optimize some quantity for a given
objective are there questions so far so
please do not hesitate to a interruptive
law question face ok this was ok this
stands indeed for winner and loose um
these are just normal space yes it other
states and that one can observe maybe
you say but they can understand how how
is it specified what is observed and
what is not observed is in patterns
tomatin or is it on the run i mean it it
it's in the model and so mostly in
though I stopped to talk i'll be
studying this kind of model in which you
don't observe the precise state of the
system but you observe let's say an
equivalence class so maybe when the
system is in state 2 you don't know that
it's it instead to be to observe that
class one two three and yeah no more so
far okay maybe we can go through that
example if if initially the system is in
state 1 and then the user execute and
okay action a okis then the observation
would instead one two or three will be
the same just because it's confused with
the three the history states and so the
user wouldn't know whether the system is
is in set one two or three okay so this
is what this cloud represent and the
objective in that particular example the
objective values are is to go to the
winning state but since they don't know
whether the system is in two or three
then they won't be able to play let's
say action be your accent see because it
would be losing for one of the states so
sorry i did not necessarily want to go
into more details on that particular
example but yea mostly will consider
mother's in which you have equivalence
classes on the on the state on the
lesson side you when you describe your
side
you can see certain actions were seems a
bit different yeah so on the left hand
side indeed it was different the idea is
you just observe events so you just
observe letters but you don't upset all
of them you don't absorb those that are
in clouds no but you can in fact you can
transform into the the other model okay
so this was a motivation for studying
systems with probabilities and partial
observation and trying to control them
so I start with quite old model the one
of prosecco da Matta so it's different
from political summit I think that Frank
mentioned in the morning which were
segalis poetic automata and our Pro is
dakota matter buy you happiness so
motivating motivating example for
pricing automata is the one of a
planning control a very very simple plan
control so imagine you want to plan your
holidays your next holidays and but you
like to play plant them in advance so
you'd like to before leading you home
you want everything to be settled so
first the first thing to do is to choose
ok and then an airline and maybe an
airline type here so either local store
i cost and then you can book once you
have your plane tickets you can book an
accommodation and this you could do over
the internet or iphone and then once you
chose your accommodation you might be
interested in choosing a tour and this
could be I want to see all autumn is
nothing ok these are two options and we
assume here that each action may fail
with some probability so this is our
represent dear let's have a problem so
we start here at all and then we chose
either a low-cost company or icons
company if which choose an ID codes
company then we praise you one will make
it let's say the plane is more reliable
and we'll make it to the airport because
the plane will indeed depart from
yeah they did the origin however if you
choose a locust action then sorry
low-cost airline then with some
probability the plane will be cancelled
that I won't be able to make it to my
holidays this is very subjective but you
can instance instantiate with different
names here now when we reach the airport
and depending on whether we booked the
accommodation on internet on over phone
then again that could be a problem and
maybe you don't make it to the hotel and
so on well I think you understood the
semantics and given a plan so plan is
just a sequence of choice so I choose an
online I choose an accommodation how to
book the accommodation to the tour what
is the probability that it succeeds then
see by succeeding I mean going to this
success state and you can compute it as
a product of probabilities and maybe if
there are several paths then you need to
some of the different paths so why is it
a partial observation problem well it's
really because you need to plan in
advance so you need to give the old plan
before leaving ok you don't know what
will happen after the first step and so
you start and you don't know whether
you'll be at the airport or in the face
state but still you need to decide to
your second action ok so as we see the
control strategy there are really words
so you say what I'll do in first step
second step and so on and and you can
wonder for each control strategy what is
the succeeding probability so what is a
priority to reach the final set of
success state after some world so here
is our we can compute it you can think
really of it as a product of the initial
vector initial distribution of other
states then this is the concatenation of
all individual matrix for each letter
each action and here you are the final
vector so which states have found just 0
ones
of course you'd be interested in optimal
strategies but as Martha mentioned in
the morning in a different setting
optimal strategy may not exist in
general so it's very easy to see that
for example on this example if I so we
initially starting to zero with pretty
one and assume you want to reach q1 so
one good way to HQ one is to choose
action B because b can lead to q1 okay
but you can see that it only leads to k
1 241 off so of course if you play a
long sequence I've base then you'll
increase the probability to HQ one that
you'll never I mean you you have an
increasing sequence of probabilities but
you'll never reach one so there's on
that example there is no optimal
strategy okay so given that there are no
two more controlling strategy we may
wander I mean another objective could be
to find good enough strategies so
strategies are that ensure some
probability level so how to specify that
then well you can define the language of
an automaton as so given a threshold
theta and some comparison operator as a
set of words so that that their
probability yeah agrees or meet that
threshold okay unfortunately the problem
if you are given a pro sick automaton of
telling whether such a language is empty
or non empty SAR is undecidable so this
is a result bypass already a few decades
back so this essentially means that you
cannot tell whether there is a good
enough strategy okay it is surprising
yeah the
so just to go a bit further this
undecidability result is some our robust
why well you can refine that that
non-internet question so for example if
you assume that you start with a very
specific very yeah a prosecutor metal
with a very specific property and what
is this property the property is that
either some word is accepted with high
probability so greater than one way to
settle or all of them are accepted with
very small probability so you really
know some kind of separation property
not really but then you cannot decide in
undecidable to tell which is the case
okay so this is very strong it means
that the efficient my opinion it means
that the addy celebrity is very robust
you know excellent a sortie I just told
the rich one look even if an angel given
an epsilon yeah it's sounds crazy so you
could think okay but maybe this is
because you you're not playing on the
threshold and the precision of the
threshold and so the threshold I mean
this one half and this is what makes
everything your difficult but if I don't
take one off but if I take one is it
easier so here I ask maybe a slightly
different question which is as in the
example I it before so does exist a
sequence of words such that there are
the limit of the probability is 1 so can
I get arbitrarily close to 1 and this
problem there quite recently was shown
to be a undecidable as well so it's not
not only very specific quantitative
questions or indiscernible but also
qualitative ones and then it was so this
undecided second and disability result
was refined by nathan allen and others
so if it the automaton you are given at
beginning i doesn't have real
probability values but parameters so
just parametric priority values and if
you ask whether they exist evaluation of
the
these parameters that makes this
property holds so value one proverb
value one or if you also ask whether all
evaluations make that proper tools it's
still undecided okay so that this can be
considered as rather bad news because s
all you cannot decide whether there are
good enough controlling strategies okay
so is anything decidable yes there are a
few decidability result for pricing
automata so if you do not want value one
problem that you if you ask whether that
there is some word accepted with pretty
exactly one then this is decidable and
it's a piece place complete problem and
it's basically equivalent to the not
basically it's equivalent to the
University sanity program for
non-deterministic finite automata so why
is that so if if some word is exactly
route 41 find out what this one means
that all computation of the that word
our end in some laxity accepting state
so if you take the compliment of the
accepting site in a it's the same as the
complainant automaton is not universal
okay another question which seems at
first close to the emptiness program is
decidable so what is this program it's
the quantitative language equivalents so
you're given to predict automata and you
ask whether for all words they give the
same acceptance probability so this
program here so it's much stronger than
asking whether the boolean languages are
equal you really ask for the
quantitative languages to be equal then
this problem can be decided in the
printed word time and it's it condition
as a consequence of some more general
result by urchins and LJ and was later
discovered or at least prove in that
particular context by tank and the
argument shows there are just linear
algebra arguments
and the proof gives a bound which is
polynomial on the length of I mean if
the equivalence as an old then you have
apple in your bath bound on the length
of witness that the two languages are
not equal okay so this is time remaining
ok so to recap on that part and I'll try
to be a bit quicker on the second one so
again in prosecutor matter there is some
kind of partial observation because the
plan is we decided in advance the model
of the system is known so if you choose
a plan if you choose a controlling
strategy then you can comp recompute
what will happen you can compute the
sequence of the distribution of the
states that you lad after each step
however this doesn't this is not
sufficient to a to get decidability of
most optimization problems ok so in the
next part I'd like to extend some are
the model of prosecco to matter with the
following so if when you execute a plan
you have some feedback of what's what
happens in in the system and you were
able to modify the plan depending on
that feedback so we'll come to a model
that probably most of you know which is
the one of partially observable markov
digital processes so it's a the one i
will present is a very specific surface
of it I still got them partially
observable NDP's so an example of the
problem in which PMD PSR can be used is
a violent of mackerel maze so we assume
that you have a rabbit so the
that has limited Center abilities and
also its moves are in perfect so what do
I mean by this so you have a base which
is represented here and you have ear I
don't know how many cells ten eleven
eleven cents and you assume that when
the robot is in this maze and it can
only see which words are surrounding it
but not the preset cell so maybe it says
so for example here in that upper corner
it is that there's a left wall and an
upper wall and in that sense it is an
upper one on the down wall and so on
okay so it cannot distinguish that son
from that one okay it's going to
distinguish either of those three cells
and what as what r is its actions so the
actions are to move north west so far
east but we assume that they are not
implementing inflam ented in a very
accurate way so if you if it should is
not then it will go to LA for priotiy
two thirds and maybe in the other
possible directions with other
probabilities okay so you know the
observations the robot receives are
really the walls so those tuples but not
the process set and the objectives so
initially the rocket is placed
arbitrarily on the grid and the
objective is to reach that target cell
and also to optimize the number of steps
towards our ability okay so now what are
strategies in such models well
strategies really map histories of what
does it happened so far because now you
you can update your plan plan depending
on what happened so what happened so far
is a sequence of actions and
observations so actions is a and
observers are Omega and it maps it to a
distribution of our possible actions ok
so we're listing which to kind of
strategies in the sequel pure strategies
where you don't have a distribution but
you have just an action
and what what here I called belief based
strategies so what I mean by believe
based strategy is a memo Ella strategy
so it only depends on the current set of
possible states okay it does not depend
on the whole history but just on the set
of possible sense let's say the robot is
in okay so what is this comment here
yeah okay so the link between a PMD
peace and privacy khatta meetha a word
in the prosecco tamata exactly
corresponds to a pure strategy in a
blind pure mdp so by blind i mean that
the observation is always the same
independently of the state the set of
obsession is a singleton so as a
consequence all the unnecessary thoughts
we add for price ticket a maternal leave
two LEDs which is not a good news ok so
for pricing automata we are always
interested in words accepted so finite
words and kind of which ability for
permed efficient we can be interested in
more elaborate objectives so rich
ability eventually some target state is
reached safety so always you stay out in
in the safe zone aboushi so infinity of
a new visitor target states and again
here would like to evaluate which is the
best part the supremum of probabilities
that overall strategies so overall news
that an objective is satisfied
Oh so first in order to ever read this
then very nice result is that it does
not need to consider all strategies
especially that they are uncountably
many one can restrict to pure strategies
so to deterministic strategies because
yeah deterministic strategies always
subsume randomized ones okay okay so as
I said the only undecidability results
from the Prosecco tonight I believe to
Palm DPS but beyond that we have more
undecidability results so for example if
we consider a beauty condition so repeat
irritability with positive probability
then this is undecidable okay okay more
other if we another example is the one
of combined objectives so if we want to
ensure grantee to objected at the time
so the first one is a beauty objective
of 41 and second one is a safety
objective of positive probability each
of them is decidable when you do it
separately but if you want a strategy
that combines both then it becomes
undecidable okay so it was a proof idea
for the first statement but in the
interest of time i'll skip it so you can
find it I can explain it later if you
are interested okay so what about
decidability well the good news is that
almost all decidable problems for our
Pro staccato matter they remain
decidable for this larger class which is
pom dp's so for example if you consider
a safety objected that you want to go
aunty with 41 then so okay maybe I won't
list all them but these three problems
they are desirable for public peace and
they can be decided in the exponential
time and that
complete that class so what is the idea
to get those x time algorithm so what we
do is a power set construction in which
you consider the beliefs so the possible
set of states the system is in and then
you compute some adequate fixed points
on that structure on that extra little
structure in the first and third problem
we can show that belief based strategies
surface are sufficient but this is not
the case of the second problem for
positive safety and okay maybe I can
give this example so here with your
model where we are four states and the
the user how the agents cannot
distinguish between state Q 1 and Q 2 so
because of this cloud air and we
consider the goal of staying in 20 q and
q 2 so avoiding you free with positive
probability so any okay the way to
ensure that is to start with a and then
do be an alternate between a and B
forever so if we start here with a then
the system is here we've party off an
ear we've pretty off so let's
concentrate on this earth probability
then we if we alternate between B and a
the B will automatically move there
because you be with protein one moves
there and then a will move to q2 again
with 41 and we can continue the
alternation and stay within the safe
area okay the other the the remaining
privacy half would lose ok I won't
detect this but would lose at some point
but sin if you internet and before
rather than you run T 0 positive
probability to stay in the safe area
which is not the case for any belief
based strategy because a billet based
strategy would either play a or b or any
convex combination of the two but
because the distribution is fixed
eventually you end in newark you free
almost surely
okay so i said most of the decidable
problems for prosecuting atty women
remain decidable in this product context
well they're still up to my knowledge
one problem which for which we don't
know so and this is the one so this is a
problem which is not to be disabled for
privacy curtain latter but open for prom
dps the question is whether there exists
a strategy such that under that strategy
the okay there's a positive proportion
of visits to the final set so not only
want to visit the set of handset
infinitely offenders with a positive
proportion and this happens with
positive probability so again we know
that this is decidable for poetic
automata but it's not known whether it
can be extended to two pontipines okay
so I'd like to n by 2 by discussion on
such models all problems so okay maybe
one lesson is that systems with a
probability special observation control
are difficult to handle so what did we
see we saw that most optimization
problems are undecidable so most
decision problems associated with
optimization problems are undecidable
and okay of course I mean of course yeah
quite obviously quantitative questions
are very easily understandable but also
we saw that some qualitative questions
already are undecidable and we also saw
that the end I try to convince you that
the entire video cetera was very robust
okay so this is these are not so good
news but I think see that there is some
hope so it may be your family to go to
this way around so what what do we
usually do when the problems are
undecidable well there are several
approaches one of them is to restrict to
decidable subclasses and in the context
of prosecco tow mater and the value one
problem then again
Ellen others studied a glass of liq
tight 40 kilometers so sub class of 40
matter for which the problem is
decidable another way is not to restrict
the model the class of models but the
class of strategies so quite often if
you restrict to find out memory
strategies even if you don't know a
priori abound on the memory size then
you obtain some designer VT results so a
I did not mention any references because
there are lots at them and another usual
way around is to approximate so if you
don't know how to answer the problem
precisely then go for approximations so
in these PhD thesis you propose some
approximations techniques for pub dp's
so the of course because of the
undecidability ok this is something I
did not mention maybe the undecidability
of even approximating the value of a
pricey automaton there will be no
termination grantees to that
approximation scheme but ok maybe on
some instances it will give some result
ok and so these are the usual things
what one does when problems are
indiscernible that yeah I'd like to
discuss another alternative which is a
discretization but which has been
different from the discretization or
approximation ear and more precisely the
idea is to approximate continuous
distributions by large discrete
population so let me explain on the
other picture so this ok on the left you
have a pretty sick automaton and by the
orange portions here I wanted to present
the probability distribution so we have
one fourth in the left state and free
fourth in the right state ok and as I
said for basic automata if you given a
plan a word you can always compute after
each step how is the priority mass
distributed over States so you can
compute such things
what if we approximate this distribution
by a number of discrete elements so for
example I have eight elements and so I
have two of them in the left side a
fourth and six of them in the right
state well you could see that if you
increase the number of those elements so
if you increase the size of the
population then somehow it approximates
the the continuous behavior however
depending on how you interpret this then
the what happens for large populations
if you increase the number of elements
is not in the limit is not what happens
in the continuous case so let me just
detail this so for example here if you
want to okay if you want two digit that
state infinitely often with 21 and this
is not feasible on that pro astok
automaton okay maybe here you need to
believe me but if you fix the number of
an average a large but fixed number of
elements then it will be feasible there
because intuitive what happens here is
that each time a is played all the
copies here of the element here will
stay there but and here approximately a
half of them will move to the right so
because this is discrete at some point
all the discrete party mass will move to
the right and then you can do B and you
can start again okay so the fact that
the limit behavior is not the continuous
behavior condition as a drawback because
okay it's not really approximating you
order a problem but we can also see it
as a very nice property because then
there is hope that some problems that
are undecidable in the continuous
semantics become decidable in this
discretized semantics so we can hope
that these alternative 70s for poetic
automata has more decidability than the
natural 10 is too I go on okay thanks a
lot earlier on you talked about
robustness of undecidability maybe you
talked about here and I missed it so
apologies if I has to repeat something
but if I were to say modify some of the
probabilities at random or introduced
noise into the system this being the
idea that this model is an approximation
reality so that we shouldn't take the
numbers in the model itself you
carefully like so how set how sensitive
is it is undecidability to those types
of modifications yeah so precisely if
you like even if I have less constrained
and what what you say so I don't even
assume I start with some probabilities
and add some noise to the values I
assume that I just have parameter so I
have p1 p2 and I want to know whether I
can assign some evaluation to that
parameters so that some property is
satisfied then this is still undecidable
I mean depending on the property but for
four properties I've discussed here so
so it really means that at least I
interpreted as it is not the case that
the precise value of the probabilities
induces undecidability even if you have
some flexibility it it would still be
understandable thank you
to p1 p2 p3 p4 in this statement you you
are allowed to choose them yeah you want
your choosing them they stare yes you're
right yeah maybe you can leave more
disability so entered by another name I
mean the result is robust in the
following sense and find a class of
automata for which whatever you put
whatever values you choose the answer
will be the same so if you p1 p2 p3 or
p1 prime P to point if you find then the
answer is the same so it doesn't even
matter what the numbers are just it's
just enough that they're here and then
the answer to your question would not
depend on this so the problem is
reversible decidable in that sense but
if you enter a state a second time and
then can you change from p1 to peep on
one that I think that was a so okay you
can find a case in which it doesn't
matter for which it is still undecidable
meaning that for instance if you want to
go bigger than half then you will have a
tomato for which it's true for all
different piece that you can choose but
you can choose them dynamically or ok so
in who's this here undecidability result
that you mentioned than everybody in
that green uber for surprise he must
construct an exam it might start from
this must be a reduction so sure that is
you can construct an automaton for which
the anticipated wrong becomes this
example X ability is that automaton what
are the probabilities then you can use I
mean the values you can use FF just
earthen 10 elfwyn is sufficient if you
just want half for you cover yes you can
this isn't this a Lebanon also if you
have a boy sokoto Martin with a single I
think correct me if I'm a single boy
seek bunching to just one state with a
basic branching this is also undecidable
so it's very very obasanjo difficult to
identify a sub class which is meaningful
and still has some good properties but
it is the example that you showed us
here there is to be a discontinuity
discontinuity so yeah yes move to
rational numbers then suddenly you mean
hashanah yes ashalon you mean in the
yeah in the opposite asian of the
distribution yes yes so it's not
completely clear yeah it's something yet
a bit different so it's not only that
not only that I consider her Russian
approximation of those of discontinuous
distribution but also so maybe it was
not very clear but also possible if we
start from there and apply a then each
such element oh yeah will we fight it
off independently with IDF loop or go
right so it's a bit different from
discretizing with a given position at
each step I i think i will show you the
answers your question
simply admit so you can ask the question
now what to what questions aren't
answered incorrectly by the
approximation on the right hand side
maybe that oh yeah so I don't add them
completely now I can tell you just now
but you can discuss later so they are
indeed some for some problems the this
approximation is a the limit is the
answer that you get there it's okay we
can get the but then we if i remember
correctly we end up with problems that
we know this edible here and so okay
maybe it's interesting but it's less
interesting than i would say that in in
that case thank you very much right now
i'm with a human on four o'clock here
the bed